There's the,
you talked about the availability heuristic and some of the role that the press
might be playing,
the fact that negative events stand out.
We can also see negative events all over the world now,
so we can't fake of all over the world.
Whenever you hear about a negative event,
it's as if it's happening next door and this is,
he is a threat.
So are the breadth of our news is exaggerated and the coverage is exaggerated,
but there still seems to me to be this,
this mystery at the bottom of all this,
which is in the face of such radically good news.
Why is there such an insistence that the system is corrupt?
We're going to hell in a handbasket then that,
you know,
human beings are a cancer on the planet and everything is heading towards the
apocalypse.
It's,
it's so,
it's so deep and,
and it doesn't seem to be moved by the fact much.
I kind of think sometimes that it's a hangover from the cold war,
you know,
that was so deeply pessimistic for so long.
Uh,
I think it goes back before the Cold War.
It certainly as a,
as a psychological syndrome,
it goes back at least to the Old Testament prophets who combined kind of social
criticism with,
uh,
for telling a apocalyptic disaster that slat that syndrome.
That combination of,
uh,
moral schooling with predictions of doom is something that our species quite
naturally falls into.
Part of it is frankly,
certain amount of,
uh,
perfect interprofessional competition that society has various elites.
Uh,
there's the politicians,
the business people,
the military,
religious elites,
the academics,
the journalists,
and they're always kind of competing for status.
And since intellectuals don't deserve a whole lot of credit for getting society
to run for,
for putting food in the stores and that keeping the peace and,
and,
uh,
protecting the streets,
it's very easy to,
uh,
to look down on other societal elites on,
on government,
on business and to say,
well,
you guys are all failing and we're the ones who are morally refined enough to
point it out.
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't put down just a sheer human competitiveness.
I'm not the first to say this.
One of my favorite explanations of the veneration of,
uh,
of the past of Golden Ages comes from Thomas Hobbs who said competition of
praise inclined to a reverence of antiquity or men contend with the living,
not with the dad.
Yeah.
Well it also seems that the,
um,
there's a certain amount of resentment that is driving that as well.
And that would go along with the status competition because there's anger,
I suppose if you're a member of any meat group to see that your paradigm,
let's say isn't leading the charge forward.
MMM,
that's right.
And you talked about the astonishing in global poverty and a part of that story
is it did not come about through massive redistribution,
which for,
for many people on the left was the only route to lifting up the poor,
namely to,
to redistribute resources.
Now that have been of course,
adjust adjustments either to shocks the fact that China and India and Bangladesh
and Indonesia have risen out of poverty,
uh,
came in part of the expense of manufacturing jobs in the United.
Yeah.
That's not exactly what people meant by redistribution.
And it literally is a redistribution of resources.
Uh,
although it is a shaking up of the economies of many,
many nations.
But this massive increase in the wealth of that Asian countries did not come
because it was horses were,
uh,
were shipped from the wealthy west to the impoverished east.
Right.
So that's also a threat to the doctrine itself.
Direct threat,
the fact that wealth is being produced and it's being distributed to people at
the low end means that implies that that redistributive philosophy is likely in
error.
And you can understand why that might be regarded as a catastrophic threat,
particularly to people on the radical left.
Well,
certainly,
certainly for,
for a radical notions of redistribution,
but at the same time,
the more limited kinds of redistribution that have,
uh,
that are ubiquitous in wealthy countries,
I have a graph showing that the amount,
the proportion of GDP allocated to social spending a skyrocketed in the 20th
century from about 1% to about 22% in every developed country.
No exceptions.
Uh,
and,
uh,
thanks to,
to spending on the cooler on children on the sick,
uh,
on the online rates of absolute poverty have fallen in,
in a wealthy countries.
So not only,
uh,
have,
has been developed developing worlds become wealthier and not directly at the
expensive of the developed world,
but it within the developed world,
thanks to some amount of social spending,
I guess you could call it redistribution.
The even as inequality has risen,
poverty has not.
Right,
right.
I wonder,
I was just reading a book by Walter Shadelle called the great leveler.
Yeah,
excellent.
It is an excellent book.
And one of the things he did was an empirical analysis of left versus right wing
governments,
I think across the 20th century,
but it might've gone farther back to now to see if there is any difference in
the Gini Coefficient across the classes of government.
And what he found was that there was no difference whatsoever.
He makes a fairly strong case that the only redistributive techniques that work
are,
um,
pestilence and war essentially.
And that's because they knock everyone down to zero.
But you're making a different case,
like an incremental case in some sense,
which is that governments perhaps regardless of their ideological proclivities
in the 20th centuries as they've become more wealthy,
they have incrementally devoted a larger part of their,
uh,
of their resources to incremental improvements in,
you might think about it as an investment in the future rather than
redistribution or investment in social capital education and healthcare and
those sorts of things that,
well,
it's pounded with some,
it's probably some combination.
It's a combination of investment in public goods because of course the whole
society is better off if the,
if everyone's educated.
I also want assurance people support,
uh,
a a safety net.
That's the most popular euphemism for social spending because you never know
whether it's going to be you or your or your mother or your brother who is going
to be,
who's going to be a need in the lottery of misfortune.
I had been,
part of it's part of it is,
is a,
is charity.
He,
the modern conscience won't allow the little match girl to freeze to death.
The jokes to Barry,
Grandpa by the side of route 66.
And so I think social spending has been pushed along by,
by all three.
Uh,
it hasn't necessary in some countries it probably has reduced the Gini
Coefficient in western European countries,
which have a more,
uh,
aggressive system of taxation then in the United States or Canada.
But more important than the Jenny distribution is that it's reduced the number
of people living in poverty,
which is the morally relevant measuring in any case.
Yeah.
So those two things are complicated because obviously you want to raise people
out of abject poverty.
I mean that's,
that's a,
that's a zero argument proposition and that seems to be happening very rapidly.
The theme,
the question after that I suppose is to what degree does the remaining degree of
inequality that's generated by productive capital assistance also constitute a
social threat?
Is there is evidence it was reviewed best buy in the spirit level,
that as inequality increases rates of male homicide,
for example,
increase in all sorts of other negative measures.
So there's some weird interaction between raising absolute levels of wealth and
ensuring that inequality doesn't,
I don't know,
exceed some hypothetical optimum that that needs to be considered in social
policy.
There I cite some skeptical re analyses of the,
uh,
the data in the spirit level and,
probably absolute prosperity matters more than inequality in determining a
social health include such as happiness,
crime,
um,
other kinds of social pathologies like drug addictions.
Uh,
it's,
it's not easy to,
to tease them apart.
No,
definitely not.
These,
you know,
countries like Sweden are a very egalitarian,
but they're also very rich,
are a more lopsided,
but they're also very poor.
And so it takes a little bit of statistical wizardry to type them apart.
And my reading of the literature is that it's actually prosperity that is more
important than that in any quality.
But also,
and this is a,
a,
that I in the psychological literature was emphasized by Christina Storman's and
Paul Bloom,
that what people sometimes think of as an,
uh,
as an aversion to inequality,
to people having different amounts is actually an aversion to unfairness
injustice.
Yeah.
That,
but people that really infuriates people is that they think that the people at
the top half ill gotten gains equal.
If they sense that the system is basically fair,
that either greater effort,
talent,
or even luck,
uh,
result in an unequal distribution,
by an impartial library,
for example.
They're okay with that.
It's cheating that really gets under,
yeah,
people are really good at remembering cheating and recognizing it as well.
And stitching.